30 degrés hier encore à Calvi c'est
dingue oui on va continuer de les avoir
voir de les dépasser pour ces prochains
jours les températures vont rester
élevées avant de vous parler
sérieusement de cette journée de mardi
regardez je sais pas si vous l'avez vu
le petit surfeur qui est tombé là ça va
faire rire ce matin je voulais commencer
la journée avec un petit peu de légèreté
c'était à Anglet hier non ces images de
la plage de Seignosse dans les Landes
n'ont pas été tournées cet été mais bien
aujourd'hui 27 degrés fin octobre des
conditions certes agréables pour les
vacanciers mais qui interroge on a
presque plus chaud que fin juin un
certain endroit donc c'est incroyable
décembre dernier déjà il faisait il
faisait ce temps là on était là le
premier du lendemain à se baigner vous
avez du réactualiser la carte qui était
déjà très alarmante qui imaginait la
météo en 2050
par exemple en 2014 vous imaginez vous
imaginiez qu'il ferait 26 à Brest en
2050 et en fait en 2050 il fera 37 à
Brest alors c'est pas moi qui
l'imaginait c'est le service de
climatologie de Météo France qui
travaille très sérieusement et
constamment d'ailleurs sur des
projections de ce que sera le climat un
jaune prometteur ces boutons de
chrysanthème éclore ont-ils à temps pour
égayer les tombes à la Toussaint pas sûr
j'ai peur que aussi fait très chaud
aujourd'hui
car la star des cimetières souffrait
aussi du réchauffement climatique et de
cet automne aux températures trop
printanières
[Musique]
[Rires]
personne ne peut compter ses
réchauffement climatique il existe ah
simplement la conversation arrive si
c'est la responsabilité des hommes ou
pas tout à l'heure on va recevoir cet
homme-là qui explique qu'il y a 20 000
ans
tout à l'heure on va régler tout à
l'heure on va recevoir cet homme là qui
s'appelle Olivier Postel Vinet il y a 20
000 ans il y a eu un réchauffement
climatique rend 40 ans mais là
n'empêche pas l'homme était responsable
ou pas si on n'a pas une période de
repos de la végétation les arbres ils
vont se comporter différemment pas de
repos non plus pour ce cerisier qui
refleurit il pense carrément qu'il est
de nouveau au printemps en ce qui fait
que en gros il s'est il s'est il a fait
de la matière organique pour rien si
c'est une année de temps en temps ça
prend encore aller il peut souffrir il
peut résister mais si chaque année les
végétaux au perturbés il peut
s'affaiblir donc être plus sensible aux
maladies au ravageurs et finir par des
périr à gauche les relevés habituels du
mois d'octobre à droite ce d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'à 8 degrés d'écart à Biarritz et
même neuf à Lyon
en Alsace il faisait 24 cet après-midi 8
degrés de plus que la normale les
Strasbourgeois ont du mal à reconnaître
leur ville ce qu'il y a c'est que il se
réchauffement climatique s'accélère ou
c'est surtout ça parce que l'année 2020
ça a été l'année la plus chaude le mois
d'octobre il est pas terminé mais on
sait que ce sera le mois d'octobre le
plus chaud jamais enregistré ça fait 9
mois d'affilée que l'on est au-dessus
des normales de saison donc on vit des
choses que l'on avait jamais vécues
selon les météorologistes cette vague de
chaleur tardive et durable est inédite
mais le phénomène risque de se
reproduire à l'avenir on a déjà eu par
le passé des pics de chaleur ou des pics
de douceur de 3-4 jours mais là
aujourd'hui on est au 11e jour et d'ici
la fin du mois on sera peut-être 17
jours 18 jours scientist rébellion des
scientifiques qui appellent à une prise
de conscience c'est plus fort à une
révolution climatique avec à peu près le
même procédé sauf qu'il n'asperge pas là
il se colle les mains au sol alors
certains de ces activistes vous allez le
voir son collait la main chez un
concessionnaire auto allemand on les
voit ici autour d'une Porsche sauf que
le concessionnaire en question n'avait
pas vraiment envie de les écouter il a
fermé boutique il a quitté les lieux
sans chauffage ni lumière ils ont passé
42 heures sur place collé au sol moi
déjà le cheval de Troie dans la vraie
vie je sais pas du tout qui c'est mais
du coup c'est une infiltrée moi je vois
pas le rapport avec un cheval pourrait
être très honnête bon moi tant que tu
vas pas faire allégeance et que tu as
infiltré chez les autres tout va alors
s'il faut taper cheval de Troie quel
cheval 2
[Musique]
chez nous on dit oh bah on arrive le
temps de tuer un âne un coup de figues
[Musique]
ça veut dire
on a le temps de tuer un âne à coup de
figues molle ça veut dire que les filles
elles sont tellement molles que en plus
de ça on a le temps de le trucider à
coup de figues il est l'un des rares
peintres inauguré de son vivant un musée
à son nom en mai 2014 le musée soulage
ouvre ses portes à Rodez en présence de
l'artiste et de François Hollande alors
président de la République pierre
soulage était ton peintre mondialement
reconnu premier Français à avoir dépassé
la barre des 10 millions de dollars pour
un tableau c'est un fatigable
travailleur ne s'est jamais vraiment
arrêté de créer pierre soulage s'était
éteint la nuit dernière il avait 102 ans